foreign
uh oh here we go sorry chat um page five
second paragraph
um it's it's got a note of
um a contribution I made where it says
that I found the report difficult to
relate to and would prefer to receive a
data chart
I'm not sure I asked for a data chart
I'm trying to remember what I did ask
about but the the following sentence
um
gives an illustration of the difficulty
had so I think what I was asking for was
um more explanation of of jargon and
terminology and Clarity on
who who Commissioners and providers were
so I know we've got a lot of data charts
tonight but uh
um just um just for clarity thank you
we've got that noted now
and um we'll ask uh councilor Taylor to
sign those uh then it says she actually
chaired that that meeting yeah
item three is Declarations of Interest I
know we'd normally need to record some
uh typically for people who work for the
Health Service so
yeah
Council Brophy
so it's the usual ones
sorry
this is working uh Council briefly as
previously declared I'm an NHS worker
yeah
okay I don't know also whether myself
and uh Pete Ward my name is Jonathan
Miller I'm the service manager for drug
and alcohol Services
um for greater Manchester Mental Health
Trust I work across Barry Bolton Salford
and Trafford both myself and my
colleagues Peter border for NHS
employees
if everyone's declaring their uh
representation
all right
thank you
um as far as questions from the public
and I have not received any I'm assuming
there aren't there aren't on thank you
um so item five is a cancer diagnosis uh
to receive a report from the director of
Public Health
I don't think that's working but
we'll need we'll need you to use one
that is working so that it does go out
on the
on on the webcast
brilliant
I think that's that's working thank you
so um this this piece of work um thank
you very much for asking me to come and
report back on this this piece of work
um as you probably know cancer rates in
Partington are High
um and they're higher than we would
expect even given the deprivation of the
population we
um a GP in Partington approached me
three years ago saying that she felt
that the rates were very high and
wondering if there was a particular
environmental reason for the cancer
rates and whether there was something we
needed to be investigating I then in um
got the help of the council registry to
do an analysis of the deaths between
2010 and 2017 and they found that the
rates were high but that it was unlikely
to be caused by a single environmental
Factor
um because of the types of cancer that
were being just that people were having
so what seemed much more likely was that
the cancer rates are high but they're
actually caused by a number of
um behavioral factors including often
linked to deprivation so that might
include High smoking rates High use of
alcohol
um low levels of physical activity and
high rates of obesity so
um we have agreed and we've been
approached since actually by Carrington
residents asking us to have a look at
the rates there we've agreed that we
will re we will ask the cancer registry
to rerun the data and their analysis in
probably 20 at the end of this year or
the beginning of next year we don't want
to do it immediately because we need to
have time for the impact of the pandemic
to work through because we know during
the pandemic people are more likely to
be less likely to be going to the doctor
so we might have some late diagnoses and
that services are just building back up
again so we wanted to give some time for
the impact of the pan endemic to go
through however we didn't want to wait
and do nothing in between and so we have
been putting in a number of steps to try
and reduce the behavioral risks from cut
that leads cancer and actually usually
often give a heart disease risk as well
so that we can improve the health of the
people of Partington the report you've
got describes some of the things that
we've been doing and I just wanted to
draw your attention as well and I can
send this around separately I apologize
for not including it in the report but
we've been doing a enhanced program with
one of the GP practices in Partington
looking at e-cigarette provision where
we're giving it as a 12-week offer the
stop smoking is Services mainly provide
the support has provided mainly over the
phone the GP directly supplies the
liquids for The Vaping kits
um out of hours we've got two different
devices so people have a choice and we
also and we engage people through the
health checks program which you will
already know about as well as Word of
Mouth for in the last from February 2022
to 20 January 2023 we've had 93 initial
consultations 57 quits which is a quick
rate of 61 which is a very high rate for
a stop smoking service that 97 that um
57 quits that we've achieved in that
year compares to four quits in the total
of 21 22 4 in the total of 21 2021 none
in 1920 and three in 1819 so we're
really proud and pleased with the impact
that that's making but
um I think the general finding we've got
is that our population in Partington has
worse Health than you would expect even
given the deprivation and that we would
really like to we're already doing work
through the neighborhood working and the
neighborhood plan worked really trying
to focus on how we can engage our
population in Partington and our
residents there more effectively and
support them to achieve Behavior change
so I think that's all I wanted to say
thank you
thank you it clearly is an important uh
important uh area of work and it's um
it's pleasing to hear how much is is is
going on it's just
um
I think we just need to uh examine every
opportunity of uh uh for work that can
be done in in that area because uh where
where
a particular type of problems such as as
cancer is
identified geographically it it does
give a scope for for work work to be
done so it is a
um not only is it pleasing that there is
this work being done but I just think
that there is um
that further opportunity to to look at
what other uh areas can be covered
um and see also if there's some
resources that can be
the channel That that way
um I mean we know
without it doesn't need me to spell it
out with Partington
um has has enough problems isn't it it
doesn't need to be burdened in in this
particular way as well so the more that
can be brought to the table
um the better uh it is uh I've not had
any committee members catch my eye yet
but let's go on now so come to the
Brophy
okay
and thank you for the report on cancer
in Partington you said in your
introductory talked to send 94 quits
working with a GP I couldn't find that
in the report anywhere so I wonder if
you could let me know where that is in
the report it's it's separate data and I
will send it to you I can send it to you
separately I apologize it was 94 93
initial consultations leading to 57
quits 57 quit in this last in the last
year so I just had a question about the
um 57 quits that you mentioned in your
um report and it was through working
with the GP so my question is
um it is quite High isn't it that's a
really good success rate what was it
about the particular way you organized
those quits that
um made it successful was it working
with the GP was it other factors and how
sustainable do you think that will be
over time so I'm confident that it will
be sustainable but whether we'll make
continue to maintain that high quit rate
I'm not convinced because we may have
got the people who were most willing
straight away because we've had such low
rates up till now
um we know in part into in Trafford in
general our smoking rate is below the
national average for all adults but we
have significantly higher rates in our
routine and manual workers and in
particular in our population with
serious mental illness we've been
offering the e-cigarette support to quit
for a while now in Trafford and had very
good success rates from it often that's
been done through pharmacies but in
Partington we decided to do a particular
push on working with a Jeep one of the
GP practices because we know that people
um take
um advice from their GPS take it much
more seriously and that g EPS off and
get a much better quit rate so the offer
is out there for the rest of Trafford
but actually what we'll be doing in
future for the next round of this will
be off continuing to maintain this and
continuing to have that offer but the
next group of people that we're really
interested in
um having a big inroad into quitting is
our people with serious mental illness
and so we'll be looking at how to work
with particularly Community Mental
Health Trust and with achieve Trafford
to to address that but that offer is the
offer that we've made in Partington is
actually available across the rest of
Trafford it's worth bearing in mind that
most people give up smoking without
actually needing any NHS services but we
know that some groups of people do find
it very much more difficult to quit than
others which is why we've done the focus
in Partington and particularly given
what we knew about the cancer rates in
Partington
just a brief follow-up to thank you for
that and yes I think probably all of us
would be interested to have that extra
data on the successful quitting service
that was offered through a GP and any
other information you've got about that
will be nice to hear
foreign
oh right yes now it is uh councilor
Leicester hail Central
um I was just actually I think I found a
little bit of the answer to my question
already which was um about how
addressing the sort of the low take-up
of screening and some of the things that
are hearing about the idea of taking the
breast screening mobile to Partington
rather than asking the people to travel
so it's actually just interested to hear
a little bit more about any of the